Remember membership at join Pacman dot com.
The number one most reliable, most exciting,
most beautiful way to support the David Pakman
show, grab a membership at join Pacman dot
com.
We do have hatriot mail. We can't possibly
get this close to an election and not have
hatriot mail reminder about what Hatriot Mail
is, because Koven, 19, is just another liberal
hoax promoted by the fake news media.
But if President Trump gets it, you better
not make fun of him because this is serious.
Hey it memo written by patriots who hate David
Pakman because of America and because freedom.
OK. There's actually a really important topic
that I want to discuss, which is brought up
in this edition of Hatriot Mail. Take a listen
to this.
David Leuser is such a cry baby. Go back to
your safe space and don't forget to give your
support gibble a hug. God, you leftists are
such snowflakes. Trump twenty. Trump is better
than Obama. FDR, any other president we had
since Lincoln. Stop hating. How much will
you cry when Trump is reelected? I want to
see it. You better stream it, love.
So this continued idea of how much will I
cry it when Trump wins? More like if Trump
wins. Listen, the polls aren't looking good
for Donald Trump. If Trump wins. It's good
for me financially. I've said this before.
I'm not pushing for Joe Biden because it would
be good for my business. It's obviously better
for my show to be in the opposition. And the
truth is, living in Massachusetts, I'm relatively
insulated from much of the day to day damage
that Trump does. Obviously, you know, when
I go to another country, I'm embarrassed to
be coming from the United States when Trump
is president. That doesn't change regardless
of what state I live in. But this entire idea
of I will cry when Trump wins. I will be sad
for what it means for the country. But it's
really not about me. This is about improving
the United States for everybody.
And I mean, it's like it's not this is not
about me. But if I'm totally upfront, we do
better when there's a lunatic in the opposition
in the White House. That's the reality. And
and that's OK. We. I want Joe Biden to win
for the good of the country. But if anybody
is expecting me to cry on election night,
you I would not hold my breath. I would not
hold my breath for that either way. Make sure
to fight hatriot TISM in your community by
using the coupon code Hatriot 40 when you
sign up at join Pacman dot com. The coupon
code saves you 40 percent and you can use
that code on any membership at join Pacman
dot com. It is spelled hkt r i o t for zero